what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we're going over all of the biggest
important details of secret Invasion
Episode 2. like Nick Fury being married
now he mentioned this in Captain America
the Winter Soldier but it was never
really brought up again and of course
the big question about this is does he
know that his wife is a scroll she was
in scroll form but then she changed to
human form when she heard him come into
the house that and we found out that
graphic is indeed creating super scroll
and he's using Groot and Cole obsidian
to do that plus the extremis this could
turn graphic into one of the strongest
villains out there plus not to mention
he is super cold-hearted he'll kill
anyone he'll kill 2 000 innocent
civilians including kids or he'll simply
kill his own people which makes sense
because in my interview with Kingsley
Ben adir who plays gravic he said that
gravic trusts nobody and nobody can
actually trust him
um love that I love that yeah I don't
think he trust me
well and that's a great part about the
shows on both sides nobody knows who
they can trust and that's very apparent
and I've I've that sort of uh amiguity
of the show I really really love but
that's great that you said that because
I think it's very real I think a lot of
people can get
untrue you know untrusting and just
blind by rage and you say I have to do
all this myself for myself and I'm doing
what I want because I'm in it alone and
I was betrayed so things are very real
yeah that that that's exactly the that
was exactly my thought I was like his
his a guy who's operating on his own
terms like he's eating
his whole life and uh and now he's
not anymore no he's saying you're gonna
eat my mm-hmm yeah love it and
that's what makes him a great villain so
we'll start with the first extremely
important scene we start off with the
flashback to 1995 the events that took
place in Captain Marvel where Nick Fury
discovered that the scroll were among
them and they needed a new home and Nick
Fury realized that the scroll weren't
actually bad it was the cree who were
bad and drove them to Earth seemingly
the scroll left Earth but Flash Forward
a couple of years to 1997 and it shows
us Nick Fury meeting with the scroll who
are on earth it shows us Vara who could
be Nick Fury's wife more on that in a
bit but Vara introduces him to graphic
our main villain of the show who when
meets Nick Fury refuses to greet him in
the scroll way touching their foreheads
kind of foreshadowing the fact that he's
not really trusting him Nick Fury but
Vira goes on to explain how talented and
skilled he is again setting up the
villain to be a huge threat now
eventually he lets Fury greet him in the
proper way touching his forehead and
this sort of sets up the trust that he
had in Nick Fury and the rest of the
scroll had with Nick Fury from the very
beginning which fuels the entire series
Halo says that the scroll who came to
Earth did so for one reason Nick Fury
and Taylor stresses how much he trusts
Nick Fury and he says he doesn't use
that word lightly so the rest of the
scroll decide to trust him as well and
Nick Fury makes a promise if they will
take human form and not expose
themselves and help Nick Fury then he
and Carol Danvers AKA Captain Marvel
will find them a home and again this
fuels the entire show because right now
Flash Forward to present time Nick Fury
and Carol Danvers have not kept their
promise to the scroll so because of that
fact many scroll are no longer with Nick
Fury and Talos they have actually gone
with ravic who has started a resistance
against not only the humans but other
scroll as well then we pick up where we
left off on the end of episode 1. Nick
Fury is over Maria Hill and yes she is
dead they have a funeral for her and
Nick Fury even has some pretty hard
moments with her mother and in a few
recent interviews Kobe Smulders has said
that's it her character is done now of
course this is Marvel Studios and if
she's not actually dead she's not just
gonna come out and say that but for the
meantime it does truly look like Agent
Hill is sadly gone now from the scene
somebody takes Nick Fury away throws him
in a van and it turns out to be halos
halos saved Nick Fury meanwhile the
scroll disguised as an American is
yelling I am an American I'm an American
as he gets captured and this is for a
very specific reason the scroll want
Russia to believe that this was an
American attack and they are successful
in doing so as we discover in this
episode then we cut to the train scene
which tells us something that is
extremely important to know for the
series and really the MCU moving forward
this is a very impactful scene Fury and
Taylor's are on the train and Nick Fury
starts to tell him about a game he used
to play with his mother it's a nice
scene and the two of them appear to be
bonding however this of course is a
tactic Nick Fury is using he says tell
me something I don't know about scrollos
and the destruction of scrollos and
basically Talos tells him that there was
a million of them that fled and now
those million scroll are on earth so
right now in the MCU there are a million
scroll in the population of the planet
that the humans really have no idea
about Nick Fury himself didn't know
about he thought that there were only a
handful of skrull on Earth maybe a
hundred a couple of hundred he had no
idea that there were millions and that
is why this is called secret Invasion
and here's where the fun kind of begins
at least to us not to the characters in
the show because we have no idea who was
a scroll and who is not at this point in
time and many insiders have stated that
there's going to be a scroll reveal that
is going to break our hearts meaning
that there's going to be a character who
we didn't know was a scroll be revealed
to be a scroll that is going to break
our hearts and right now our best guess
is on Roadie and we'll talk about that
in just a little bit but first let's
continue to talk about how the scroll
have severely impacted Earth becoming
the leaders of some huge countries and
the scroll High Council group is
basically running the world one of the
members Pamela Lawton is the UK prime
minister Sergio caspani is the NATO
Secretary General and Shooter McGavin I
mean the character that Christopher
McDonald is playing Chris Stearns is a
high-powered political person as well
and we assume the other two members who
are on the council are people of power
now we found out that graphic was not
invited to this council meeting and that
is because they were meeting together to
determine the punishment that gravic is
going to receive for disobeying the
council and essentially causing War
however graphic enters and says that is
what I want I want war because Nick Fury
promised us a home and we don't have it
yet so I'm going to take Earth as our
home for the scroll and he talks about
how humans are basically destined to
kill themselves because that's what
they've done in in the past so when it
comes to killing innocent humans they're
only kind of speeding up their
destruction Because he believes that
eventually they will cause a destruction
of themselves or ourselves I guess I
should say so gravic who has seemingly
teamed up with Pamela Lawton the UK
prime minister becomes the scroll
General and the council all except for
one stand behind him and essentially
this is the agreement for all scroll to
launch a war against the humans on Earth
to take Earth as their own and make it
their home and again all of them are
super pissed because Nick Fury did not
deliver on his promise him and Captain
Marvel did not find them a home and not
only that but both of them just sort of
abandoned the scroll altogether so
they've had it and now it's war and
graphic has a secret weapon for war and
that is seemingly to make super scroll
now in the comics the super scroll was
one character a character that was given
special powers by the scroll Emperor
Doric he was given these powers to
defeat the Fantastic Four and the powers
that he received were actually a
combination of each individual
character's powers from the Fantastic
Four so he was given the ability of
flight and pyrokinetics given the
ability of invisibility and force fields
he was stronger than the thing and could
stretch further than Mr Fantastic the
key points here being he has all their
powers but better stronger and what's
interesting is that is basically what is
happening here minus the Fantastic Four
right now gravic is sort of the scroll
Emperor now he is using scientists to
create a super scroll serum essentially
they have made this device that is going
to take the powers of certain specimens
and give them to scroll and we've
actually seen him kind of use these
powers in some trailers his arm kind of
goes out like groot's arm but it extends
like Mr Fantastic's arm and when Gaia is
examining what is happening here and
goes on the computer she can find
specimens they've taken from Groot from
a frost beast from yotenheim from Cole
obsidian from Avengers end game in
Avengers Infinity war and they even have
samples of the extremists from Iron Man
3 and this basically tells us that some
of the powers that the super skull or
graphic is going to have are pretty
similar to some Fantastic Four powers
for example the extremists could give
him the power of fire pyrokinetics the
sample from Groot could give him the
power to extend his arms and body parts
like Mr Fantastic Cole obsidian samples
could give him super strength like the
thing and the frost Beast well that
could simply give him some ice powers as
well so grabik as a super scroll is
going to be a pretty big threat now the
next important scene is roadie Roadie is
dealing with the effects of Russia and
he's pretty pissed off at Nick Fury now
in this scene it's super important
because people believe that Roadie could
be a scroll a lot of fans are in
disbelief at this scene because Roadie
basically isn't helping Nick Fury out at
all in fact it's the opposite he fires
him and he pretty much dismisses the
fact that the scroll could have already
invaded Earth pretty easily plus one of
Roadies initial reactions to what Nick
Berry was telling him was to call their
friends AKA The Avengers now Nick Fury
dismisses this quickly as well because
he knows that scroll could simply take
on the identity of Avengers and all of a
sudden The Avengers are terrorists but
perhaps that is what Roadie or this
scroll disguises Roadie wanted because
that would be what the scroll resistance
would want they would want Chaos on the
earth and what better way to cause chaos
than to take your Heroes and make them
villains but of course the argument can
be made that Rhodey is simply upset with
Nick Fury as well and has taken his job
where he's at now very seriously and is
concerned with protecting the United
States and might think that Nick Fury is
not the same Nick Fury he's not the man
he used to be and he can't handle this
task that's in front of him which could
be why he fired him but let us know your
thoughts about this down below is roadie
a scroll or is he not is he just wrote
him now the next scene is with Sonia
fallsworth and the scroll Brogan and
this scene is really meant to show us
just how intense two characters are
ballsworth and rabbit fallsworth and her
ability of interrogation and her ability
to get Secrets out of people that she
tortures and her ability to escape
basically showing us here that she is a
threat she is not someone you want to
mess with and if she is going to go up
against Fury then Fury is in trouble
although I do believe that they'll end
up working together and then we have
gravic graphic comes in and just
absolutely murders everybody there and
the people there did seem to be working
with at least in part with MI6 but
graphic shows absolutely no mercy and
wipes the floor with them and then to
top it all off graphic does not trust
that Brogan kept everything a secret and
only told fallsworth lies and he ends up
killing him while he has Pagan do it but
he is the one that made the decision
that Brogan is going to die he can't
trust Brogan and in the interview he
revealed that gravic actually can't
trust anyone so grabbeck is not Beyond
killing obviously he killed two 2000
people in the very first episode he
killed these operatives in this episode
and he killed one of his own and that's
what this scene showcases fallsworth and
gravic doing whatever needs to be done
to get their job done now the last scene
has caused a lot of debate and a lot of
theories out there with Marvel fans Nick
Fury goes home and he goes home to his
wife however before Nick Fury enters the
door his wife or The woman Inside is a
scroll then when Nick Fury gets inside
she is no longer a scroll so this begs
the question does Fury know that she is
a scroll there are some things that
point to the fact that Nick Fury
probably does know that she is a scroll
this could be Vara from the beginning of
the episode the one that introduced Fury
to graphic now there's two scenarios
here one Fury met and fell in love with
Vara the scroll and he knows that she is
a scroll obviously or two Vara is
actually secretly working for gravic the
other scroll and she has infiltrated
Fury now there is a scene in the
beginning as well where Vara puts her
hand on graphic shoulder on her hand we
can see a ring and it seems like they
are making a point to show us this
because they start with the camera Focus
directly on the ring or at least her
hand now it is on her right hand but we
don't know what significance a wedding
ring plays for scroll maybe scroll don't
use wedding rings to show that they're
married and if they do maybe they put
them on the right hand it is on the ring
finger of the right hand so perhaps this
could show that maybe they were even
married or engaged back then because
this was in 1997 a couple of years after
Nick Fury did find out about the scroll
perhaps they got engaged plus not to
mention there are some photos on the
wall when Nick Fury walks in that look
to be humans kind of taking different
forms these could be art that Nick Fury
and his scroll wife picked out together
and liked because of the fact that his
wife is a scroll and Nick Fury obviously
has companionship with the scroll it
would also be surprising to learn that
somebody has infiltrated Nick Fury he is
the Spy to quote Tony Stark so odds are
he probably does know that his wife is a
scroll he probably married her knowing
that she was a scroll but go ahead and
let us know your thoughts about this in
the comments down below and let us know
what you thought of episode 2 of secret
Invasion also only a couple days left in
her giveaway if you want to enter for a
chance to win an Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items so be sure to subscribe and leave
a comment down below this interests you
in our giveaway we pick a winner at the
end of each month the winner gets to
pick one item you can also check us out
on patreon on Discord and you can check
out our website as well we'll link all
of those down below and you can follow
us on Instagram and Twitter as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf
beep